[Music]
so i'm leilani i'm a fifth year phd
student here in csail
i work on explanatory artificial
intelligence i'm interested in processes
and methods to make sure that machines
can explain themselves especially when
they get into errors
and my long-term research is that all
machines all
processes even opaque processes like
machine learning systems
will have the ability to explain
themselves and they can be challenged in
an adversarial proceeding if they do
something wrong
and also they'll be able to communicate
with people so when we have humans and
machines working on tasks together
they'll be able to communicate in a
common language
so i'm sort of at the last stages of my
phd research
and i'm looking to evaluate the methods
i've been building for the last couple
years
so we hired on europe to do some
simulations
for the project and then work on
incorporating my methods
into the simulation to prove that it's
accurate to prove that it sort of works
in this environment
right so you have a vision system that
basically sees that
and then you have some car that's at
some you know
[Music]
angle here and if it's at enough of an
angle
you basically want sort of the brakes
engaged as well as the gas
and so we want them to basically have
some sort of like conversation back and
forth very quickly
because they're never supposed to be on
at the same time and so if you were
going to have a rule-based system it
would say okay this is like absolutely
wrong
but if you have this sort of
conversation between parts and maybe
even a planner
[Music]
that they should come up with yeah you
have to hold both of them and then you
can sort of proceed forward once
this turns green once we pick the
simulation i can see like how verbose my
explanations will be
because you know you don't want
something that's like too long and too
hard to process if you're making this
sort of real-time decision can we
be good for you eleven two on on one
side
yeah yeah works for me
my name is divyan shanwegum and i am a
phd student in the clinical and applied
machine learning group
[Music]
the lab that i'm in broadly focuses on
machine learning and health care but
what i'm excited about
is machine learning on unreliable data
so what is the best you can do with data
sets that
are maybe not labeled correctly or have
noise in their features or that kind of
thing
so those are the problems that i focus
[Music]
on
dude
i'm sort of a night person and so the
mornings are a lot of paper reading and
slower tasks
and then eventually like the afternoon
is filled with meetings or
more coding
there's an organization in the
department for the graduate women in
course six
it's called gw6 and one of the events
that it focused on running this year
was a summit to celebrate the women in
academia in the department and connect
people across years i worked with
a set of women across years to put it
together
so we're doing a walk through of the
building before the event
and we're just trying to make sure that
everything we think
is going to be there is there and just
previewing what the event might look
[Music]
like
[Music]
hi my name is harini and my research
focuses
on the ways that machine learning tools
interact with people
so this can mean anything from the ways
that people are involved in the data
collection process
and how that can lead to negative
consequences
to the ways that we can build machine
learning tools
to better serve end users
[Music]
natalie is another phd student in
computer science
natalie and i have actually worked
together on several projects
and it's really great to have someone to
collaborate with
some of the things that we work on are
related to our research and
others are related to side projects that
we're both interested in so
something that we've both been working
on over the past year is
this youtube series called ml tidbits
what exactly people mean when they talk
about
false positives or false negatives or
true positives or true negatives
the goal is to teach machine learning
concepts in a really accessible way
that's
understandable to a broad audience
there are a lot of talks that happen
around csail and
it's really nice to be able to go to
these because they're often from
areas that you don't necessarily
encounter them in your
own everyday research so it's a nice way
to
break up the normal stuff that we do
every day and
learn about research that's happening
both from students here at mit
from students elsewhere who are visiting
from other faculty
in other departments so the talk that we
went to
on data and feminism was by catherine
dignazio who's a new professor
in the urban planning department and her
research
is also really related to computer
science and data science so that was
really interesting for me
to see the ways that computer science
and the things that i'm doing
might apply to other fields and other
applications
intellectual history that we inherit
today and that we can draw from
and use in our work going forward
there are a lot of fun social gatherings
here in csail so one of
the favorite things that we do is muffin
monday
at 5 pm on mondays we go up to the top
floor and
basically any ucl graduate student can
have a free baked good
and sort of chat with friends and things
like that
muffin monday is awesome people come
from all around stata
to get these muffins free food events
are sort of a staple
of graduate student culture in the
department it's like a good place to
spend 10 to 15 minutes catching up with
people who aren't necessarily on your
floor or in your research area
and the pastries are pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
in our group we have group meeting every
week and we order lunch
and usually one or two people talk about
something they've been working on or
give a talk if they're trying to
practice a talk
sometimes people talk about preliminary
ideas or
go through things on the whiteboard so
it's basically an opportunity for
people to bounce ideas off of others in
the group
and get feedback on things that they're
working on and so it's nice to get
perspective
on the thing that you're working on from
a range of people with
different backgrounds and different
expertises
so let's start with this project which
is about data augmentation to help with
one shot
medical image segmentation now
in this particular project the medical
images that we're looking at are
magnetic resonance images or mris
if you've never seen one before this is
what they look like
[Music]
nowadays there's no in vivo objective
biomarker
for diagnosis well photons can actually
provide
an alternative architecture for quantum
computing you have a lot of data
extracting
useful information will take a lot of
human hours the
silicon photonics is the most compatible
so we don't have to reinvent the wheel
automation sensors everywhere no people
on the floor
so if something breaks we need to find
out really quickly this takes the output
of some opaque mechanism
which could be anything from the vision
system of a car or possibly a planner of
a vehicle that may be proprietary
because um
the company wants to keep that secret
and then this reasonableness monitor
then provides
an output of both a judgment so it says
whether the intended behavior is
reasonable or not
and also provides an explanation of why
obviously being at mit and in csail
there's a lot of pressure
but i've been able to make a lot of
great friends and what's nice about
being a graduate student
is you have a very flexible schedule and
i really love coffee so i try and take a
coffee break
every few days and go out with friends
so harini and divya and i will
occasionally go and get coffee
and just chat about things it's sort of
like a nice excuse to
get out of lab and to not only update
your friends about like research but
also your life surrounding that research
and sort of maintain that support
network because i think
graduate school can be isolating
sometimes and so having those moments
where
you're connecting with friends can be
really nice
[Music]
i also find csail to be very
collaborative so
at other universities i've been or in
other workplaces i would work mainly in
isolation
but what's nice about being here is i
can you know just turn my head and ask
my colleague a question and people are
always willing to help and
chat about research and collaborate and
it's just a very nice welcoming
environment
[Music]
you